[Musique]
charge journal j'ai l'impression d'être
dans une impasse
j'arrive pas à mettre la main sur la
bonne personne pour tanger ratisser
large
tellement le procédé par élimination
trop jeune trop barbu trop chevelu
propre titre engrange ou la lui la pâte
défaut ça cache un truc chez un mignon
ou vilains minions friends génial sur
cotés sur côtés par hasard tu t'es tu te
plains pas google parce que tu es tout
ce que je recherche
c'est bon d'être au milieu là c'est quoi
comme c'est un chien
oui mais je veux dire comme camarès
c'est un coton mais j'avais fast and
live j'avais compris que tu avais
compris que c'est un schéma vie sans toi
c'est comme un mur que même si le vent
est sauf les pluies qui tombent pas de
prix tu veux te remercie mon âge j'ai
raté j'aimerais moi aussi
c'est un col c'est impossible alors pour
le coup ça ressemble vraiment un chien
mais c'est le cas non mais c'est pas cgc
une petite blague 16 s'apprend pas y'a
pas d'atomes crochus et je crois que tu
as fait tomber quelque chose je regarde
au guidon qu'est-ce que j'ai fait tomber
par terre
as mon coeur je sais désormais que cette
personne et contre l'injustice qu'elle
aime les vidéos des bébés animaux qui
galèrent à descendre les escaliers que
c'est un individu de sexe masculin qu'il
a des yeux pas plus de deux par contre
il a la trentaine il est drôle il a bon
goût
l'étau se resserre tous les éléments me
pousse à penser que mon principal
suspect est en fait le garçon j'aime
bien et qui m'aiment bien alors oui je
sais j'avais classé la faire quand
j'avais compris qu'il ne quitterait
jamais sa copine mais je sais pas y'a un
truc est pas clair du coup je les ai
convoqués
[Musique]
orange
ça va pourtant note marc six poules
enfin jamais dit cela mais j'avais peur
d'arriver trop enfin je voulais pas
arriver trop tôt parce que je veux me
faire genre mais fâché avec mon chien
juste mais bon mais je compte pas ça me
fait plaisir est grave c'est quand tu
vois ça va super super super fait offrir
un verre ou un truc
non j'ai fini mon verre et j'ai plus
soif se connaît se connaît on se connaît
on se connaît mais j'ai un gros j'ai pas
mémoire non non j'ai pas de mémoire
non mais c'était pas un truc à la fin sa
série dans ce genre soucier si un truc
ans anna
[Musique]
johanna
ouais ça fera un sans lui joue pas bon
bah cool tout va bien toi ça va
ben génial je vais y aller tu sais quoi
tu m'envoies un texto tu as durement
durant
oui après je feins répondait pas je me
suis peut-être que tu avais changer ou à
buenos parce que j'enlève les
notifications ça c'était 3 dick tifo ces
trucs là donc j'ai vite mais envoie un
texto on s'écarte et puis si tu mets
salut c'est moi mon prénom et mon prénom
mais tient bel et bien voilà à quai
était bas carrément trop cool tu peux du
coup on essayait de se voir et se sont
contentés programme envoie top
ouais merci en tout cas pas de rien ciao
[Musique]
jacquart